good morning read Jack nation and in
case I don't see you good afternoon good
evening and good night ha ha
zits the majestic the majestic fect
starring Paul writing howl Newman we're
gonna watch today from the show Space
Ace The Truman Show the ethics of
fabricated realities if I break down we
did one for this channel for back to the
future about time travel which is really
cool and led to a really fun discussion
and this is a page from video request
from one of our top patrons a man named
Alex gross Alex who runs this channel
currently the man is in Thailand right
now taking advantage of all the cheap
you know the cheap DVDs you know what
I'm talking about I whispered into my
mouth so you could hear a Gollum me of
you yeah how you treat them they're not
humans
[Laughter]
hey I know three typos so I can make
that joke right and they're all women
I'm sure they'd appreciate that we're
gonna watch this video now I'm sure this
is the shadow YouTube um the nature of
your reality for Truman Burbank reality
was nothing more than an unsolicited
television just a moment of his life was
broadcast on live TV
let's take a look at his reality
somebody is dead what does this at the
beginning of the true name of Raqqa true
one begins to notice that something is
wrong with his world like a falling
spotlight from the sky rain that falls
only on hot repetitive patterns and an
experience involving his deceased father
for Truman any prospect of leaving the
island frightened sir
due to a childhood boating accident that
killed his father and instilled an
ever-present fear of water Maryland's
waha and
his best friend actively attempt to
suppress Truman's curiosity why well
it's because Truman initially fell in
love with an extra named Sylvia but when
Sylvia ran off of Truman to the beach
and revealed that his reality is fake
she was quickly whisked away never to be
seen again
Marlin soon discovers Truman's tunnel
the freedom and breaks characters Truman
escapes in search of a true reality and
sails off to the edge of the dome into
freedom
pazzo what makes the Truman Show so
terrifying well the majority of the
public is complicit in his imprisonment
the entire world watched his life unfold
with very little issue
Truman never consented to have his
privacy invaded just like the Truman
Show fans obsessed with his every move
humans have the same obsession with
reality TV in social media we suddenly
ask to see willingly with every app we
use and every Alexa or Google home we
purchased yes unlike us
Truman never opted in for forced
isolation from the real world having
been placed in the domed prison as a
baby
Truman never had the opportunity to
choose a profession or live the way he
wanted to Truman is a slave to the
corporation he was legally adopted by a
corporation and subtract the ability to
decide us fulfill our Nesta some
corporations like Facebook and Google
are already more powerful and
influential than most countries so a
scenario where companies help countries
adopt children for commercial purposes
isn't out of the question much like a
slave Truman was unable to act against
his masters will we accept the reality
of the world with which represented his
entire life was exploited for money and
entertainment The Truman Show company
likely grew Rick called it industry
leadership did his escape the Japanese
supplemental lots of profits while used
dogs to sniff out their prized work
Christophe
the producer and driving force of The
Truman Show manipulated false narratives
to prevent Truman from exploring the
world and acting with free will are we
really so different from Truman our
brains like computers follow a blueprint
that builds upon itself through
interaction with the environment Truman
was born into a safe comfortable and
trolled City it's likely that many
people on planet earth would actually be
jealous of his lifestyle on the flipside
Truman can't trust anyone because
they're completely fabricated he can't
choose to pursue who he decides to love
Meryl was selected to be his wife and
showed no real love for him
these falsified relationships made the
potential of true relationships that
much more desirable and inevitable
escape from the dome do you ever wonder
what happened next for Truman we know we
do hahaha does the company still own him
dog starters aside it's time for the
real question is The Truman Show ethical
now you say no as follows before with
technological advances in our current
society our privacy is becoming
increasingly more compromised and
without privacy captivity can take hold
as individuals we should all have the
right to be free each of us should have
the choice to decide the life we want to
live so what do you think should society
need to a problem is watching this Levin
how angry would you be if you found out
your whole life was a lie let us know in
the comments below and in case we don't
see you good afternoon good cool I don't
know what they're talking about I think
that's a perfect scenario I think it's a
perfect in there no mystery I love vlog
channels the only watched blog channel
that's my ultimate goal this is to have
a camera on me at all times that can
never truly behave as I would like to
yeah exploit your your personal life
problems I mean let's face it I have one
day where I did that and that changed my
whole life one video for one day or you
put up a personal life thing and then
you go wait a minute I don't want to be
that guy I don't like it I made a
mistake it's shaped everything yeah
what's Greg talking about I'm sure
someone in the comments will tell you no
no obviously I hate channels that thrive
off that there's so much truth of The
Truman Show and his breakdown and I
think especially with what YouTube has
with a lot of its channels in terms of a
lot of specific vlog like channels
there's a channel out there were close
to a million subscribers I've seen his
video it's trending once in a while like
saying goodbye to my best friend and my
girlfriend has cancer now I'm not gonna
go to this whole criticism about my
personal opinion on these
two channels but there's something about
those things people just love watching
someone's personal life so much yeah
they like being above the knee because I
was thinking about The Truman Show and
I'm like this guy has a boring life
doesn't do anything that interesting
yeah but think of all the watching
people live their lives yeah way to the
store right now then you could say the
same thing about watching us doing a
reaction honestly a reaction is a lot
more brief and it's not exactly an
insight into what we're doing outside of
because we're gonna talk about what
we're reacting to so there's a little
bit of difference there but well on the
reduction is like the surrogate for
looking over at your friend to see if
they're laughing oh yeah we're enjoying
the video or whatever exactly but some
might think that's pointless and some I
think that's stupid honestly I thought
reactions before i reaiiy ever did one
was kind of a dumb thing I did and then
I started doing them I started liking
and I started seeing what is appealing
about that I understand that people get
from but at first I didn't yeah the
thing is though about The Truman Show
versus vlogs is vlogs people choose
Harry
yeah that's voluntary or you're choosing
to but it's a similar type of crowd of
the kind of people who would watch
something like The Truman Show oh this
is I mean I feel like The Truman Show is
really ahead of its time in a lot of
ways yeah because of what we have now
there's so much of this across
television across the internet across
everything now there's so much of
people's mundane lives that you can just
peer in on if you want to yeah and the
only difference now is that you know
you're not enslaved to by this scenario
as so much as you I mean you might
become enslaved by it but you know
everybody enters and willingly now we
sign contracts or we put up YouTube
videos or whatever with The Truman Show
though there are things I I wondered
about because movies pg-13 was sex life
jerseys forbid you ever seen
just cut that out or the guidelines give
to trim and show a yellow dollar bills
like appropriate content it's not an
adult program because I would have loved
to have seen that I think if you remake
the trubin show only include those
scenes real no plot no storyline I think
you should do it we're Truman herbux at
a sex trap just like a weird experiment
in normalcy yeah when he finds
everyone's watching him he's just like
at least discussing the ethics of
fabricated reality I mean I feel like
this Oh completely unethical
no this guy's a slave I hope no one
steals this idea but I had a segment
idea that I came up with yesterday John
read it it's number five out of seven
second ideas I have number five why this
movie is actually I'm coining it right
now this date I feel like Truman Show is
like a real like messed up movie that
was advertised as like a family-friendly
comedy in some ways you know yeah I mean
totally if you look at the implications
I mean there's totally whimsy at hand
but to me this is in a very different
way kind of like a home alone where it's
like if you just change the tone a
little bit this would be entirely messed
up
yeah has to be really horrific oh yeah
totally like this poor man honestly if
there's a movie I would love to see a
sequel that people might deem
unnecessary it would be The Truman Show
yeah like who is he going into a real
world confronting that he's still a
celebrity because people outside that
don't have to know what are his trust
issues like yeah how could he ever know
any parent does he capitalize on fame
how could he ever escape he's the most
famous man in the world for being him
could he ever lead a normal life you
know like I would I would love to
actually
çf sequel to the tree and I think like I
hate media Jim Carrey yeah like
disassociation from a reality and a very
metaphysical kind of guy he's even got
the perfect look he can have his shaved
head exactly beard and long hair
Jim Carrey who he is now would be a
perfect fit for a troupe more than a
Dumb and Dumber to it's a Truman Show
sequel make way more sense to me and I
mean it would be totally relevant to
just acknowledging all the things that
we brought up in this video like reality
TV and vlogging and all sorts of stuff
there would be so much to draw from that
would make the commentary work as well
yeah I mean the conclusion they come to
a fabricated reality is that ethical no
I don't think so
I think it's rarely ethic clearly
ethical what you're trying to like catch
someone for doing something horrible but
beyond that like take a normal guy and
to throw them into that situation is
holy mess yeah yeah twice a legal record
people without consent yeah I don't know
if they got let him know I don't let my
therapist now yeah I record all my
therapy sessions without my therapist
knowing I record all of my massages I
record every time my girlfriend I do it
you know in case she leaves me I need
something for the ethics of revenge porn
promise the cameras only on me poetic
irony right the only frame is me anyway
guys subscribe to space tasters to do
some amazing videos I need to taste
place to place thanks Alex gross for
supporting the channel please go check
out some more of their videos hey you
guys didn't subscribe to the reject
nation and I clicked that notification
bell because you know people say to do
that and check us out on patreon where
we got [ __ ] see you guys poop